I hate that I have to do this like every
day now Pat hates it even more trust me
he's spoken to me about it ah fair but
I've got to give you another political
update Pat we've been joking like do we
need to do this every day
we do need to do it every day yeah
things have changed I was saying even
after politican we're gonna have to do
daily a schedule is for the debates so
to reset the story quickly I'm going to
politican it's political convention is
the idea political conversations panels
debates etc initially I had a couple
panels I was doing some of them got
cancelled things got moved around the
latest iteration was that Kyle kolinsky
from secular talk and I were going to be
debating charlie Kirk and Candice Owens
from Turning Point USA and it was gonna
be this big battle and it was gonna be
fantastic yesterday I mentioned that
politican advised me that while the
panel had indeed been confirmed the
panelists had not and I changed my
flight on the basis of the understanding
that the panelists were confirmed when
in reality only the panel was confirmed
which means there will be a panel hmm
but the panelists could shift last night
relatively late here on the East Coast I
got a call from politican telling me
basically I think they're not happy with
me at all
they said number one the panelists you
mentioned were not confirmed and indeed
Candice Owens is not participating we're
bringing in some guy from The Daily wire
we're bringing in Rome roving roaming
Maroney Melanie again roaming millennial
will be there as of now Charlie Kirk is
still scheduled to participate although
people have been tweeting me today that
he's out I don't know where that came
from but they told me don't talk about
panelists at all until the panelists are
confirmed and I don't even confirmed now
I'm not even really sure who knows
what's going on with Charlie Kirk either
he's participating in like ten panels or
he's not even gonna Boreum not gonna be
there I don't really know I think they
also weren't too thrilled with some of
my promotion they made it clear that
these are not debates at all so I was
can you imagine the other day I did a
video after changing my flight on the
basis that I was promoting a debate
between particular panelists turns out
the panelists weren't confirmed and it's
not a debate there's no moderator it's
just for now I
guess it's five people who are going to
be on stage so that's the latest who
knows what it will be tomorrow or come
Monday or whatever Kyle and I were
texting yes yesterday Kyle kolinsky and
I and Sam cedar and I and we're
basically all taking the approach that
we may not know what we're doing until
like five minutes before like even when
we show up to the green room it's
possible that there will be different
people there than the ones we believe
will be there or maybe even that like
the time or topics of these things may
change I don't know but that's the
latest update and the reason I feel that
this is necessary is that people are
contacting me saying I'm buying tickets
and plane tickets to go to politican to
see these events that you're promoting
and I know Kyle kolinsky has been having
the same issue and some of these events
aren't happening so I want to tell
people as soon as possible
even if you have non-refundable plane
tickets within 24 hours I believe at
this point every airline lets you cancel
just sort of if you made like an oops I
booked the wrong thing type of thing not
that I'm telling people not to go but if
you're going on the basis of a
particular event I've promoted with
peace and love I am being totally
upfront about everything I know at the
time that I know it yeah it's a leap of
faith it's kind of like gambling or you
know investing in the stock market sure
yes quite a con 2018 it's something like
that so that's the latest and hopefully
it will all be wonderful and excellent
and everybody's great that that's going
and it's just it's all going to be
fantastic and we're gonna talk about
politics kind of I'm sure what else to
say here politican coming up very very
soon